الان الى التطورات على الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه حيث اصدر الجيش الاسرائيلي
امرا بالابتعاد عن المنطقه الممتده من
بلده مناره ويفتاح ورمات نفتالي في الجليل
الاعلى لتعرضها لقصف من لبنان وقالت مصادر
الجيش ان صفره الانذار دوت نحو عشر مرات
في هذه المناطق خلال الساعه الاخيره قبل
ان يوضح ان تكرار تفعيل صفاره الانذار في
الجليل الاعلى كان نتيجه خطا في هذه
الاثناء قال حزب الله ان اثنين من عناصره
استشهد في جنوب
لبنان معنا الان من مرجعيون جنوب لبنان
مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقدي ومن الجليل
الاعلى مراسل الجزيره حسن مسعود ارحب بكم
وابدا معك ايهاب العقدي اخر المستجدات من
الجانب
اللبناني نعم قامت القوات الاسرائيليه بشن
غاره على اطراف بلده ميس الجبل المعلومات
الاوليه تحدثت عن استهداف احد المنازل
وقالت فرق الاسعاف ان احد لم يصب لم يصب
في هذا الاستهداف ايضا المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه ردت بقصف على اطراف بلده
بليده المقابله لميس الجبل والتي تقابل
كذلك مناطق مختلفه من المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه بينها يفتاح التي كانت اطلقت
فيها صف مار الانذار حزب الله هذا اليوم
نعى اثنين من مقاتليه وذلك بعد استهداف
بالطائرات الحربيه لاحد المنازل الذي الذي
الذي كان كانا يتحصن به في بلده الطيبي
يوم امس ايضا حركه امل شيعت اثنين من
مقاتليها في بلده بريده بعد ان كانت
استهدفتهم الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
قبل يومين في البلده
نفسها حزب الله و خلال اليوم الماضي كان
شن ثماني هجمات على مناطق مختلفه من
المواقع الاسرائيليه في المقابله لجنوب
لبنان وهو وان لم يسجل حتى اللحظه اي
عمليه ولكن الجانب من حزب الله كان اعلن
عن هذه العمليات التي تتسم باستهدافها ل
تجمعات للجنود الاسرائيليين في محيط
المواقع ومستوطنات مختلفه من المناطق
القريبه من الحدود مع لبنان وايضا استهدا
دا كذلك بالصواريخ التي تحمل رؤوسا متفجره
يصل زينتها الى 50 كيلوغراما احد المواقع
هناك وكذلك استهداف باسلحه مختلفه للمواقع
الاسرائيليه واللافت كان ايضا في هذه
الاستهدافات هو قيام حزب الله بشن هجوم
صاروخي على منطقه منحم منحم التي تقع
قباله عيتا الشعب وهي المستوطنه التي يطلق
ق باتجاه الاسلحه المناسبه وفقا للبيان
الذي اعلنه يوم امس وياتي ذلك في اطار ما
وصفه بالرد على العمليات الاسرائيليه التي
تستهدف فيها منازل مدنيه في جنوب لبنان
شكرا جزيلا لك